three Brave uh three Brave uh three
Brave of three folks who are speaking of
some of the bad guys that are here in
this country uh diversity hire Karin
Jean Pierre yesterday said one of the
this is one of the stupidest things that
has ever been uttered by a
representative of the White House um
well just listen for yourself what I
will say our deepest uh obviously our
deepest condolences uh go out and our
heartfelt condolences go out to the
families uh who lost uh three three
braak
uh three Brave uh three Brave of three
folks who are who are military folks who
are brave who are always fighting who
are fighting on behalf and of uh this
administration of the American people
that is absolutely incredible do you
catch the end of that who are fighting
on behalf of this
Administration those people are not
fighting on behalf of this
Administration they are fighting on
behalf of the United States of America
which hopefully will survive this
Administration we'll see about that but
they are not fighting for the Biden
Administration they're fighting for the
United States of America for at least as
long as we remain United that's also
another issue just absolutely completely
ridiculous and it gets worse with her I
mean this woman is just she's she's in
some ways she's perfect like in one hand
you could watch her and be frustrated
and be like how did this woman get the
job and okay she's a black lesbian it's
so exciting it's just great on the other
hand she's the perfect embodiment of
everything that is wrong with this
Administration uh and uh she doesn't
seem to want to pressure the president
to call any of those military families
who just lost their children um has the
president uh called already or does he
plan to speak with the families of the
Fall service members um don't have any
calls to read out uh this is a a sad day
this yesterday was a very very sad day
no we don't we don't know we don't know
if he's going to call anybody right well
you know he's busy like the guy he's
always doing stuff he's just got so much
energy U he just doesn't have time to to
call the servicemen it's just so so evil
but what's she really focused on what's
this Administration really really
focused on while Iran kills members of
our military yeah you guessed it science
is clear climate change is is the
existential threat of our time so to
yeah it's climate change the climate is
coming the climate is coming and it's
going to make her hair flat when the
humidity
Rises